Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. Or, if you're listening on the Apple Podcasts app, you can subscribe within the app in just a few clicks. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. For more than 200 episodes, Tom Holland and I have been considering the great questions of our time.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告单集、系列节目抢先体验，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要获取加更节目、抢先体验、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。或者，如果您使用的是 Apple Podcasts App，只需点击几下即可在应用内订阅。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。在过去的二百多集里，汤姆·霍兰和我一直在探讨我们这个时代的伟大问题。
The causes of the French Revolution, the origins of Dweil flunking, and the tragic fate of Graf Dietrich von Hülsen-Hesler. If you don't know what I'm talking about, you'll have to dig back into our back catalogue. But today we've set ourselves a real challenge. Some of the thorniest and most intriguing historical questions of all, with a guest who specialises in tackling only the most difficult topics. Since 2006, the podcaster Dan Carlin has recorded a series of truly gigantic podcast episodes, sometimes more than five hours long, which makes us look positively weedy, examining truly enormous questions. Alexander the Great and Hitler, the battle for the Pacific, or the death throes of the Roman Republic.
法国大革命的原因、德怀尔溃败（Dweil flunking）的起源，以及迪特里希·冯·许尔森-黑瑟尔伯爵的悲惨命运。如果你不知道我在说什么，那你得去翻翻我们的往期节目了。但今天我们给自己设定了一个真正的挑战。我们要探讨历史上一些最棘手、最引人入胜的问题，并邀请了一位专攻最难话题的嘉宾。自2006年以来，播客丹·卡林（Dan Carlin）录制了一系列真正宏大的播客节目，有时甚至长达五个多小时，这让我们显得有些微不足道，而他探讨的都是极其宏大的问题。亚历山大大帝与希特勒、太平洋之战，或是罗马共和国的临终挣扎。
And Tom, I know you'll enjoy this analogy. This is a bit of a Marvel superheroes team up, isn't it? I've no idea what you're talking about, Dan. Tom hates, Tom hates. He absolutely hates it. I'm the Hulk. You're, I don't know who you would be. Would you be that fellow who- I'd be Loki, wouldn't I?
汤姆，我知道你会喜欢这个比喻。这有点像漫威超级英雄的强强联手，对吧？我完全不知道你在说什么，丹。汤姆讨厌，汤姆讨厌。他绝对讨厌这个比喻。我是绿巨人。你，我不知道你会是谁。你会是那个家伙——我会是洛基，对吧？
Wouldn't I be Loki? You were in your dreams. Anyway, crack on with it. Yeah, well, it is. I mean, it's a great honour to have Dan on the show with us. The Elvis to our Cliff Richard, I suppose. Dan. Are we going to have to explain Cliff Richard
难道我不是洛基吗？你在做梦吧。总之，说正事吧。好吧，确实。我是说，能请到丹来我们的节目真是莫大的荣幸。我想，他就像是我们播客中的猫王，而我们只是克利夫·理查德（Cliff Richard）。丹。我们得向非英国听众解释一下谁是克利夫·理查德吗？
to our non-British listeners? So you were well ahead of the game because you were doing a history podcast 16 years ago. Is that right? Is that when you started? We had a current events one start in 2005 and then a history one in 2006. Yes. And at that stage, so podcasting was pretty niche, I would say, wasn't it? I mean, it was, had the, I mean, did the iPhone exist? Did people, how do people listen?
所以你当时相当走在前沿，因为你在16年前就开始做历史播客了。是这样吗？那是你开始的时候吗？我们从2005年开始做了一个时事节目，然后从2006年开始做历史节目。是的。在那个阶段，播客可以说是相当小众的，对吧？我是说，当时，iPhone存在吗？人们，人们是怎么收听的？
Well, it's funny because we had been sitting on this show idea for a while and somebody who had just come over to the company I was working in from Apple had said to me, you know, that show that you kind of got, you know, just sitting on the shelf waiting for the right time to release. He goes, I can't tell you why, but he goes, release it now. And so we released it. And it just turned out that was the month that that Apple started supporting podcasts on its iTunes platform. And so the month we started was the I want to say it was like July or somewhere in there, 2005. And that was when we started was the I want to say it was like July or somewhere in there, 2005. And that was when Apple first started supporting podcasts. So it's kind of like turning up in the Klondike before anyone's arrived.
说来有趣，因为我们这个节目的创意已经搁置了一段时间，而我当时所在公司的一位刚从苹果跳槽过来的人对我说，你知道你那个一直放在架子上等待合适时机发布的节目吗？他说，我不能告诉你为什么，但他说，现在就发布吧。于是我们就发布了。结果证明，那正是苹果在其 iTunes 平台上开始支持播客的月份。所以我们开始的月份是——我想大概是2005年的七月左右。那就是我们开始的时候——我想大概是2005年的七月左右。也就是在那时，苹果公司首次开始支持播客。这有点像在任何人到达之前就来到了克朗代克（Klondike）淘金热现场。
The bottom line is, it's just absolute serendipitous luck. And it's taught me, I think, a lot about history, where you look and you go, OK, so a lot of things maybe fall into that same category where you say, how did Julius Caesar end up in this place at this time? Was it Julius Caesar's doing or was he just lucky? And on the topics. So for those people, your podcast is called Hardcore History. And I mean, it is pretty hardcore. It really makes us look positively soft core, Tom. That's not something I'd often say about us by comparison, because your episodes are enormous. You'll do a sort of series on the Pacific war and it's sort of five episodes that are five hours each. So have you memorized all the stuff beforehand or how does that work? Well, let me just say that the first episode
归根结底，这纯粹是天意般的幸运。我认为这教会了我很多关于历史的道理，你会发现并感叹：好吧，很多事情可能都属于同一类情况，你会问，尤利乌斯·恺撒（Julius Caesar）怎么会在那个时间出现在那个地点？是恺撒自己的决定，还是他只是运气好？说到这些话题。对于那些听众来说，你的播客叫《硬核历史》（Hardcore History）。我的意思是，它确实相当硬核。汤姆，这真让我们显得有点软核了。相比之下，这不是我经常用来形容我们的词，因为你的节目体量太庞大了。你会做一个关于太平洋战争的系列，大概有五集，每集长达五个小时。所以你是把所有这些资料都提前背下来了，还是说它是怎么运作的？嗯，我只想说，我们做的第一集
we ever did was 16 minutes. So that shows you what I was thinking it was going to be. So this evolution is totally contrary to anything I would have chosen because as you guys know, as podcasters yourself, it is really hard to do five and a half hour long shows and then listen to them and edit them and all that,
节目只有16分钟。所以这表明了我当时对它的预期。这种演变完全违背了我的初衷，因为正如你们所知，作为播客同行，制作长达五个半小时的节目，然后去听、去剪辑，以及做所有这些工作，真的是非常艰难，
and then all the stuff that ends up on the cutting room floor. In terms of memorization, no, I have to do all of the prep ahead of time in terms of a lot of these topics are things I knew something about anyway, right. I'm not starting from ground zero. Somebody said to me once, why would you please do a show on 17th century India? And I said, I can't do a show on 17th century. I know nothing about 17th century that information I used to know is still valid? And so you start from the foundational level there and you read a lot. And then I usually mark down little quotes that I want to include in the program. But then we go in and we sort of freewheel because it ends
还有那些最终被剪掉不用的大量素材。至于背诵，并没有，我必须提前做好所有的准备工作，而且很多话题本来就是我多少了解一些的，对吧？我不是从零开始的。曾经有人对我说：“请做一期关于17世纪印度的节目吧。”我说：“我不能做17世纪的节目。我对17世纪一无所知，我以前掌握的信息现在还适用吗？”所以你得从基础知识开始，阅读大量的资料。然后我通常会记下一些想在节目中引用的名言。但接着我们就会自由发挥，因为节目最终会
up becoming something that you never could have planned for better or for worse, if that makes sense from an evolutionary standpoint. And Dan, what you also do do so you great narrative sweep but you also you focus in on on the big questions that i'm sure people are always asking themselves so alexander or hitler are they really so different that kind of thing um and so that was really our inspiration for what we thought we we talked about with you as dominic said we we have discussed some of the big, big questions of history on our podcast. But we thought that to go to the next league, we've got you here. We could ask you perhaps 10 questions that we've prepared in advance, and we could discuss them. And I think that the 10 that we've chosen are absolutely probably the 10 biggest questions in the whole field of history.
变成你永远无法规划的样子，无论好坏，如果从演进的角度来看这说得通的话。丹，你所做的还有，你拥有宏大的叙事脉络，但你同时也聚焦于人们肯定会经常自问的那些重大问题——比如亚历山大和希特勒真的有那么大区别吗？诸如此类。嗯，所以这确实激发了我们的灵感，让我们思考可以和你聊些什么。正如多米尼克所说，我们在播客中探讨过一些历史上最大、最宏大的问题。但我们觉得，为了更上一层楼，我们把你请到了这里。我们可以向你抛出我们提前准备好的大约10个问题，然后大家一起讨论。我认为我们选出的这10个问题，绝对可以说是整个历史领域中最重要的10个问题。
That's a very big claim, Tom. I should say for our listeners, our regular listeners, we obviously didn't prepare them together because there would be far too much bickering. So we each prepared five. You can judge who chose serious, intelligent, wide-ranging questions, and who chose the sort of questions that you'd see on a quiz machine at a pub in 1988.
汤姆，这个口气可真不小。我得对我们的听众——我们的老听众说，我们显然没有一起准备这些问题，因为那样会有太多的争吵了。所以我们各自准备了五个。大家可以评判一下，谁选的是严肃、睿智、视野广阔的问题，而谁选的又是那种你在1988年酒吧的问答机上能看到的问题。
I want you guys to know something. When we decided to do the history show, my original intention was to do it for people like you, right? I had never intended to do shows for people that didn't know the history. Tom, what does he mean by people like us? I mean people that know the history, right? And so we were just going to talk about the weird questions that you were referring to. And I thought, OK, I'm not qualified to teach anybody history, but I can talk about the weird questions. And it was only when you found out that a lot of the listeners didn't know the background story that we started giving more background.
我想让你们知道一件事。当我们决定做这个历史节目时，我最初的打算是为像你们这样的人制作的，对吧？我从来没打算为那些不懂历史的人做节目。汤姆，他说的“像我们这样的人”是什么意思？我指的是懂历史的人，对吧！所以我们本来只打算讨论你们刚才提到的那些奇奇怪怪的问题。我想，好吧，我没有资格教任何人历史，但我可以讨论这些奇奇怪怪的问题。直到你们发现很多听众并不了解背景故事，我们才开始提供更多的背景。
But my intention had been to talk to people like you who knew this stuff and then just say, isn't it weird that, you know, blank, blank, blank. So go ahead. The questions. Yes, we'll see what we can maul. OK, so here is the first question. I think this is probably the biggest question of all, and I'm sure that Regis professors at Oxford and Cambridge would agree with me on this. Okay, so here we go. University challenge, yes.
但我的初衷一直是跟你们这些懂行的人对话，然后说：“难道不奇怪吗，你知道的，某某某……”所以，请吧。这些问题。好的，让我们看看能擦出什么火花。好吧，这是第一个问题。我认为这可能是所有问题中最大的一個，我相信牛津和剑桥的雷吉斯教授们也会同意我的看法。好吧，那么我们开始吧。大学挑战赛，对吧？
Dan, who would you least like to be besieged by? A, the Assyrians, B, the Romans, or C, the Mongols? I'll repeat. Do you need to repeat? A, the Assyrians, B, the Romans, or C, the Mongols? Okay, so I have a little clarification question. Who am I? Am I just a common citizen in this city, or am I someone in a leadership or position of authority? I think that's up to you. OK, that's I mean, that's a fruit. That's a fruitful avenue to to discuss.
丹，你最不愿意被谁围城？A，亚述人；B，罗马人；C，蒙古人。我重复一遍。你需要重复吗？A，亚述人；B，罗马人；C，蒙古人。好吧，我有一个澄清的小问题。我是谁？我只是这座城市里的一个普通公民，还是某个处于领导或权力的位置上的人？我想这由你决定。好吧，我的意思是，这是一个富有成效的方向，
So let's let's start off by saying that you are the person in charge of the city. OK, then I'm going to say I want to be besieged by the Mongols because I think they have the least good chance of getting into the city. I think the Assyrians and chance of getting into the city. I think the Assyrians and the Romans, it's going to be 100 percent. I'm in deep trouble. Whereas the Mongols sometimes didn't have the greatest siege situation. It depends on who they captured and who they were bringing with them. But I mean, if you catch the Mongols at certain periods of time and in certain venues, sometimes they had a harder time. The Romans and the Assyrians always had their gear with them. They were ready for sieges most of the time. The Mongols, sometimes it would have been just as devastating. Other times they might have ridden around your walls for a long time, you know,
我们可以展开讨论。那么，让我们首先假设你是负责这座城市的人。好吧，那我会说，我希望被蒙古人围城，因为我认为他们攻入这座城市的几率是最低的。我认为亚述人和罗马人攻入这座城市的几率是百分之百，那我可就大难临头了。而蒙古人有时并没有最强的攻城条件。这取决于他们俘虏了谁、带了什么人随行。但我的意思是，如果你在某些特定时期、特定地点遇到蒙古人，有时他们攻城会遇到更多困难。罗马人和亚述人总是随身带着攻城装备，他们大多数时候都为攻城做好了准备。蒙古人有时可能同样具有毁灭性，但另一些时候，他们可能只是在你的城墙外兜圈子很长时间，你知道的，
and not been able to do much. So if I'm the leadership, in which case I'm dying when any of these people get a hold of me, then I think the Mongols have, and they all probably have a pretty good chance of taking my city, but I think they have the least good chance of those three individual groups. Maybe that's a good way. I think that's it. I'd answer the Mongols, Tom, but for a different reason. Am I not right in thinking that if, I mean, I know, Dan, you've done a podcast about Genghis Khan Avenue, and we did one about, a couple about Genghis Khan a few weeks ago. Am I not right in thinking that the Mongols, if you surrender immediately, you can probably collaborate with them?
却做不了太多事情。所以如果我是领导者，在这种情况下，这些人一旦抓住我，我必死无疑，那么我认为蒙古人——虽然他们所有人拿下我城市的几率可能都相当高，但在那三个特定群体中，他们的几率是相对最低的。也许这是一种不错的说法。我想就是这样。汤姆，我会选蒙古人，但理由不同。我没记错的话，如果——我知道，丹，你做过一期关于成吉思汗的播客，我们几周前也做过一两期关于成吉思汗的节目。我没记错的话，蒙古人如果你立即投降，你或许可以和他们合作，对吧？
So you're saying you take the coward's option, Dominic? I don't think it's a coward's option, Tom. I think it's that, given that the alternative is to be part of a pyramid of skulls or similar. As I have already said, you have the heart of a eunuch. We call that living to fight another day, don't we? Yeah, exactly, exactly.
所以你是说你选择当懦夫，多米尼克？汤姆，我不认为这是当懦夫。我认为，鉴于另一种选择是成为骷髅金字塔的一部分或遭遇类似命运……正如我刚才所说，你有着一颗太监的心。我们管这叫“留得青山在，不怕没柴烧”，对吧？对，没错，绝对是的。
It's the alternative brave option. So Tom, what do you think the answer should have been? Okay. So if I'm going to surrender, it would definitely be the Mongols. Because if you surrender- So all that eunuch stuff was just- Yeah, but I'm not going to. I'm going to carry on fighting. And in that case, I definitely don't want to be captured by the Mongols because I think it would be awful. I think I would go with the Assyrians on the assumption that I'm not the leader and that I'm a woman. I think if you're the leaders, the Assyrians are going to flay you alive. Yeah, but that's the proviso. I'm not the leader,
这是勇敢的另类选择。所以汤姆，你觉得答案应该是什么？好吧。如果我要投降，那绝对会选蒙古人。因为如果你投降——所以刚才那些太监的言论只是——对，但我不会投降。我要继续战斗。在这种情况下，我绝对不想被蒙古人俘虏，因为我觉得那太可怕了。我想我会选择亚述人，前提是我不是领导者，而是一个女人。我想如果你是领导者，亚述人会把你活活剥皮。对，但这是前提条件。我不是领导者，
because that would be awful. That's why I asked that at the beginning. That's right. No, so I'm saying I'm a woman with children and that therefore hopefully i will be taken away into exile and set up in a nice kind of cushy billet in nineveh or something like that i agree however dan that if you're the leader probably the mongols is the one to go for what would the right what's the roman practice when they sack a city when they take a city do they have kind of three days license or something they um well according to polybiusbius, they not only kill everybody in the city, but all the animals as well. So he said that you could always tell where the Romans had been because all the dogs and cattle and horses would be cut into pieces too. But Dan, you answered as a leader. What if you're not a leader?
因为那样太可怕了。这就是为什么我一开始要问那个问题。没关系。不，所以我是说我是一个带着孩子的女人，因此希望我会被带走流放，并在尼尼微（Nineveh）或其他地方安顿在一个舒适的小住所里。不过丹，我同意如果你是领导者，可能选蒙古人是最好的。罗马人在洗劫一座城市、攻占一座城市时，他们通常的做法是什么？他们有所谓的三天特许期之类的吗？他们——嗯，根据波利比乌斯的说法，他们不仅会杀死城里的所有人，还会杀死所有的动物。所以他说，你总能认出罗马人到过哪里，因为所有的狗、牛和马也都会被砍成碎片。但是丹，你是站在领导者的角度回答的。如果你不是领导者呢？
If you're not a leader, I mean, when the Romans sacked Cremona, those were Roman citizens that they treated that way. So, I mean, obviously all three of these groups are known to cause great damage and harm. But I think if you're not the leader and again, I think we have to ask whether or not slavery is better or worse than death, because I think slavery is what you're going to get in most of these situations. Also, I think the Assyrians might spare the common citizens that you're probably going to be relocated and slavery is going to be what's going to happen to you. But I think the Mongols kill everybody. And again, the Romans depend. I mean, if you're Julius Caesar, he was kind of known for clemency. You might get off easy. I don't know. Especially if you're in the middle of a civil war and he's trying to sort of get some propaganda props against his opponents. Yeah, so that's a good point.
如果你不是领导者，我的意思是，当年罗马人洗劫克雷莫纳（Cremona）时，他们对待的可是罗马公民。所以，很明显，这三个群体都是以造成巨大破坏和伤害而闻名的。但我想如果你不是领导者——同样，我认为我们必须探讨奴役是比死亡更好还是更糟，因为我认为在大多数情况下你面临的都是沦为奴隶。此外，我认为亚述人可能会饶恕普通公民，你可能会被重新安置，沦为奴隶将是你的命运。但我认为蒙古人会杀死所有人。同样，罗马人则视情况而定。我的意思是，如果你是尤利乌斯·恺撒，他以宽大处理闻名，你或许能轻易脱身。我不知道。特别是如果你正处于内战之中，而他正试图借此捞取一些对抗政敌的政治宣传资本。是的，这倒是个好点子。
So it depends also if you're a Roman or a Gaul. Yes, absolutely. Yeah. Because the sack of Cremona, which happened in the year of the four emperors, I mean, that was viewed as a terrible crime by the Romans themselves. So probably if you're a Roman, you'd want to be besieged by the Romans. But you wouldn't want to be a Gaoul besieged by Caesar, would you? You've done loads of stuff on this. Isn't his claim that he killed a million ghouls?
所以这还取决于你是罗马人还是高卢人。是的，绝对的。是的。因为发生在四帝之年的克雷莫纳劫掠事件，在罗马人自己看来也是一桩滔天罪行。所以如果你是罗马人，你可能会希望被罗马人围城。但你肯定不想当一个被恺撒围城的高卢人，对吧？你做过很多这方面的节目。他声称自己杀了一百万高卢人，难道不是吗？
I mean, that seems wildly inflated, doesn't it? Or Dan, if you've done your podcast about this, is it true that he killed a million ghouls? I forgot where we – I think that's a modern estimate. I don't – and Tom may know this. Yeah, Plutarch says that. Plutarch says that Caesar killed a million and enslaved a million. And it's probably an exaggeration, but not that much of an exaggeration. I mean, I think Caesar's campaign in Gaul was on a genocidal scale. And also, he was very into mutilating prisoners. So he demonstrated his clemency by not killing ghouls, but chopping off their hands.
我的意思是，这个数字看起来被严重夸大了，对吧？或者丹，如果你做过关于这个的播客，他真的杀了一百万高卢人吗？我忘了我们在——我想这是一个现代估计。我不知道——汤姆可能知道这个。是的，普鲁塔克（Plutarch）是这么说的。普鲁塔克说恺撒杀了一百万，又奴役了一百万。这可能有些夸张，但也没有夸张得太离谱。我的意思是，我认为恺撒在高卢的军事行动达到了种族灭绝的规模。而且，他非常热衷于虐待战俘。所以他通过不杀高卢人而是砍掉他们的双手来展示自己的仁慈。
Well, see, there you go. So anyway, he's practically a humanitarian. I know, liberal. Liberal. So the upshot was the Mongols, was it? So I think, yes, I think the Mongols. Yeah. Okay.
你看，事情就是这样。所以不管怎样，他简直成了一个人道主义者。我懂，太自由派了。太自由派了。所以最后的结论是蒙古人，对吧？所以我想，是的，我认为是蒙古人。好吧。
How weird, wait, how weird is that, that we all chose the Mongols? That's got to be the only time. You set up the discussion so that that would be the only time you would ever pick wanting to be captured by the Mongols. Go on, Tom, what are you going to say? Well, I was just saying that we've definitively answered the first big question in history. So that's one down, nine to go. Okay, very good. Let's go on to number two then. So number two, Dan. Which world leader do you think made the biggest difference to the course of the 20th century oh which world leader made the biggest difference i i'm gonna say that it's going to be um kaiser wilhelm i think i think i think starting a friend of the show yeah i think to me that is and i always think about this from a German perspective.
多么奇怪，等等，这不是很奇怪吗，我们居然都选择了蒙古人？这绝对是破天荒头一次。你设计这场讨论的目的，就是为了让这成为你唯一一次想选被蒙古人俘虏的情况。说下去，汤姆，你要说什么？嗯，我只是想说，我们已经彻底回答了历史上的第一个重大问题。所以解决了一个，还有九个。好吧，很好。那我们接下来看第二个问题。那么第二个问题，丹。你认为哪位世界领袖对20th世纪的发展轨迹产生了最大的影响？噢，哪位世界领袖产生了最大的影响？我，我可以说，这将会是——嗯，威廉皇帝（Kaiser Wilhelm）。我认为，我认为——我认为挑起了一期节目的老朋友，是的，我认为对我来说，我总是从德国的角度来思考这个问题。
I mean, if you could take back any move and you're a German, I think taking back marching into Belgium has to be. I mean, think about how different German history is if that doesn't happen. So in my mind, if you look at the First World War as being a domino that begins tumbling throughout the 20th century, then not starting that is that, I mean, you know, you can talk about Bolshevism not happening, Hitler in the Second World War not happening, the Cold War not happening. So I'm going to say, and again, I'm not pretending Kaiser Wilhelm actually controlled the mechanism that does, because we all know that there were multiple people involved in this, but I'm going to blame it on the emperor of Wilhelmine, Germany. Wow wow that's harsh tom i think that's harsh because we've discussed the kaiser in in sympathetic terms haven't we we talked about his his issue with shoes in particular
我的意思是，如果你能收回任何一个举动，而你又是个德国人，我认为收回进军比利时的决定是必须的。我的意思是，想想看，如果没有发生那种事，德国历史会是多么不同。所以在我的脑海里，如果你把第一次世界大战看作是引发整个20th世纪一系列骨牌效应的多米尼克骨牌，那么不挑起那场战争就是——我的意思是，你可以谈论布尔什维克主义不会发生，希特勒和第二次世界大战不会发生，冷战不会发生。所以我选这个，而且我并不是假装威廉皇帝真的控制了产生结果的整个机制，因为我们都知道有多方人员参与其中，但我还是要将此归咎于威廉时代的德国皇帝。哇，哇，汤姆，这太严厉了。我认为这太严厉了，因为我们之前曾以同情的心情讨论过这位皇帝，不是吗？我们讨论过他——特别是他对鞋子的执念。
yes so so dan we're very interested in um the snub that uh k Kaiser Wilhelm received when he went yachting with the British royal family off the Isle of Wight, and he wore the wrong shoes. And we have asked whether this perhaps was the turning point in 20th century history. Are you suggesting that they should have gone easy on him? I mean, there are standards after all, Tom. Well, Tom is bitter about this, Dan, because he once wore the wrong shoes on a yachting holiday.
对，所以——所以丹，我们对威廉皇帝在怀特岛（Isle of Wight）外与英国皇室一起乘游艇时受到的冷落非常感兴趣，当时他穿错了鞋子。我们曾探讨过这是否可能是20th世纪历史的转折点。你是在暗示他们当时应该对他手下留情吗？我的意思是，毕竟还是有标准的，汤姆。好吧，汤姆对此耿耿于怀，丹，因为他有一次在游艇度假时也穿错了鞋子。
Oh, I see. So I have a lot of fellow feeling. I also think that's harsh because Nicholas II also, you know, he signed the mobilization orders. And when he did so, said to his generals, you know, this is a very bad move. I feel very bad about this. So he equally could have taken a decision not to escalate although i suppose you would say he equally was basically a prisoner of the decision making kind of process in you know the summer of 1914 well but what happens if okay if you don't if
噢，我明白了。所以我对此很有同感。我也觉得这个说法很严厉，因为尼古拉二世（Nicholas II）也——你知道的，他签署了总动员令。当他这么做的时候，曾对他的将军们说，你知道，这是个非常糟糕的举动。对此我感觉非常糟糕。所以他同样可以做出不让事态升级的决定，尽管我想你会说他基本上也是1914年夏天那种决策过程的囚徒。不过，如果发生这种情况——如果
belgium doesn't get invaded one could one could argue and you could tell me if i'm wrong about this but one could argue that you could have a regional war or you could have a war between Russia and Germany or power blocks in Central and Eastern Europe. I mean, it is only when Belgium becomes invaded that this becomes something that turns into the monstrosity that it was. I mean, let me ask the question this way. If Germany and Russia go to war with each other and Belgium is not invaded, do you think Britain goes into the First World War? Oh, that's a difficult question. So we did a podcast about the origins of the First World War. So people who listen to that will know that I have very heretical views. So people always argue in Britain whether we should have fought in the First first war or not and i i think we should but but on the other side um okay but i crack at the french but i think so
比利时没有遭到入侵，人们可以争辩——你可以告诉我我对这一点理解得对不对——人们可以争辩说，你可能会爆发一场局部战争，或者爆发一场俄国与德国之间的战争，或者是中东欧权力集团之间的战争。我的意思是，只有当比利时遭到入侵时，这场战争才变成了后来那种惨绝人寰的庞然大物。我的意思是，让我换个方式问这个问题。如果德国和俄国开战，而比利时没有被入侵，你认为英国会加入第一次世界大战吗？噢，这是一个棘手的问题。我们曾做过一期关于第一次世界大战起源的播客。所以听过那期节目的听众会知道我有着非常异端的主张。英国人总是争论我们当时是否应该参战，而我认为我们应该参战——但在另一方面——好吧，我对法国人有点意见，但我想
so the french so the french so the french were always going to fight the first world war i mean there's no doubt about that um and i think the germans thought didn't they that basically the only way i mean their entire military machine was predicated on the idea that they would strike west and they would have to do that through belgium right so so germany going to war with russia i i don't think there is a scenario in which they don't go through belgium because i think they felt that was an absolute because that was their plan wasn't it there was that was always the plan but they couldn't ignore the French. I mean, France is, they think we knock out, we have to deal with France first. And the only way to do that is to go through Belgium. I mean, I think, but I think the bigger question is, well, it's not if, I suppose what to me the question is, is what if Britain nevertheless stays out? Because it could have, if the Germans had gone into Belgium in a different way, maybe. If that's the case, then you could say that it's
法国人——所以法国人——法国人总是会打第一次世界大战的，我的意思是，这是毫无疑问的；而且我认为德国人当时认为，难道不是吗，基本上他们整个军事机器都建立在这样一种设想之上：他们必须向西进攻，而这就必须通过比利时，对吧？所以德国与俄国开战，我不认为存在一种他们不经过比利时的情景，因为我觉得他们认为那是绝对必须的，因为那是他们的计划，不是吗？那一直都是他们的计划。但他们无法忽视法国人。我的意思是，法国是——他们认为我们必须先击溃法国，必须先生存下来对付法国。而做到这一点的唯一途径就是穿过比利时。我的意思是，我明白，但我认为更宏大的问题是——好吧，这其实不是“如果”，我认为对我来说的问题是，如果英国无论如何选择作壁上观会怎样？因为如果德国人以另一种方式进入比利时，也许是有可能的。如果是这样，那么你就可以说，
whoever makes the final decision to involve Britain. Herbert Henry Asquith. Herbert Asquith is the most important. Well, I don't think the United States gets in the war if Britain's not in the war. So I think that's true. That's true. When I wrote that
那是任何做出让英国卷入其中的最终决定的人。赫伯特·亨利·阿斯奎斯（Herbert Henry Asquith）。赫伯特·阿斯奎斯才是最重要的人。嗯，如果英国不参战，我认为美国也不会参战。所以我觉得这是真的。这倒是真的。当我写下那个
question i was i was guessing that you would choose either hitler stalin or mao but hitler and stalin are both created by the first world war that's right that's so if the first world war goes differently then neither of them are part of the equation so for example if the first world war britain isn't involved and germany wins quickly then is there a bolshevik revolution well but but isn't isn't i mean a popular theme of counterfactuals in which Germany wins and defeats France is that France then produces Hitler. Yeah. Wow.
问题时，我猜你会选择希特勒、斯大林或毛泽东中的一个，但希特勒和斯大林都是由第一次世界大战造就的。没错，确实如此。所以如果第一次世界大战的走向不同，那么他们俩都不会成为这个方程式的一部分。举个例子，如果在一战中英国没有卷入，而德国迅速取胜，那么还会有布尔什维克革命吗？不过，不过——难道不是吗？我的意思是，德国获胜并击败法国的另类历史（counterfactuals）中有一个很受欢迎的主题，那就是法国随后催生了希特勒。是的。哇。
Wow. Hitler. Well, you know, here's the thing that no one ever considers either. But what if, you know, during the initial stalemate of things, peace talks had broken out and somehow they'd manage in 1915 or 1916 to sort of end this thing with an armistice then with none of these countries destroyed or, you know, or I mean, that would have been interesting to the United States wouldn't have been involved. See, here's the you guys know much better than I do. But the damage to the British Empire in this war from the financial standpoint and everything else, I mean, I don't know if you call it a mortal wound, but the bleeding that happens
哇。希特勒。好吧，你知道，还有一个从来没有人考虑过的情况。如果，你知道的，在最初的对峙僵局期间，和平谈判已经爆发，不知何故他们在1915年或1916年设法通过停战协议结束了这场战争，当时没有任何这些国家被摧毁，你知道的，或者——我的意思是，那将会很有趣。美国也就不会卷入了。你看，这就是——你们比我更清楚。但这场战争对大英帝国在财政及其他各个方面的破坏，我的意思是，我不知道你是否称之为致命伤，但从
from that moment on is such that when we talk about, you know, impact on the 20th century, I mean, imagine if Britain had not been mortally wounded then and the role that they might have played in a 20th century world as a much more healthy, great power. I mean, the counterfactuals, as Tom was suggesting, are fantastic. Yeah, I think that's true. But to play devil's advocate, you could argue that Europe was a tinderbox waiting to explode. Oh, yeah, Bismarck said so, didn't he? Yeah, that if it hadn't been the Kaiser, it would have been someone else. And you would also, on the topic of Britain, say relative to America,
那个时刻开始的失血是如此严重，以至于当我们谈论（你知道的）对20th世纪的影响时，想象一下如果英国当时没有受到致命伤，他们在20th世纪的世界中作为一个更加健康的超级大国可能会扮演的角色。正如汤姆所暗示的那样，这些另类历史真是太美妙了。是的，我想这确实如此。但为了反驳，你也可以争辩说，欧洲当时就是一个随时准备爆炸的火药箱。哦，是的，俾斯麦（Bismarck）就是这么说的，不是吗？是的，如果不是威廉皇帝，也会是别人。而且关于英国，你也会说，相对于美国而言，
Britain was always going to be eclipsed by America. It was just a question of how and when, I would have thought. The scale of, you know, America is such a larger power, now a continental power. Britain's just a small island. I think that the eclipse of Britain by America was always going to happen. And the First World War probably just expedited it. I love the line that Bismarck is quoted to have said a generation before the war that that Europe's leaders were like men smoking in an arsenal. And so so so I think I think your point is well taken about about the nature of the situation. You know, the United States is a funny is a funny question on this, because I you have to remember that there was a long history in the United States of non-interventionism in Europe's situation. I mean, it goes back to the founding
英国被美国超越是不可避免的。这只是一个如何以及何时发生的问题，我是这么认为的。其规模之大，（你知道的）美国是一个如此庞大的强国，如今是一个大陆型国家。英国只是一个小岛。我认为英国被美国超越是必然会发生的。而第一次世界大战大概只是加速了这一进程。我很喜欢俾斯麦在战前一代人时说过的那句名言：欧洲的领导人就像是在军火库里抽烟的人。所以——所以——所以我觉得你们关于这种局势本质的观点是非常中肯的。你知道的，美国是一个有趣的——一个关于这方面很有趣的问题，因为你必须记住，美国长期以来对欧洲局势一直奉行不干涉主义。我的意思是，这可以追溯到建国
fathers, right? And I think if you hadn't had the First World War the way you had it, I don't think the United States gets involved in at least European affairs from that moment on. And then it would have been very interesting because, of course no first world war no second world war what is going to be this momentous event that breaks this taboo in american uh international history you know you needed something that broke down and then once the wall was broken down it was a lot easier to get back and do it again but i i don't know i don't know what America's- Something in the Pacific, maybe? Something to do with China? Well, on China, what about Chairman Mao? Because he perhaps is the obvious candidate
元勋们，对吧？我认为，如果没有以那种方式发生的第一次世界大战，我不认为美国从那一刻起就会卷入欧洲事务。那将是非常有趣的，因为当然了，没有一战就没有二战，究竟是什么样的大事件打破了美国国际历史上的这种禁忌呢？你知道的，你需要某种打破常规的东西，而一旦这道墙被打破，再想故伎重施就容易多了。但我不知道——我不知道美国的——也许是太平洋地区的某个事件？某种与中国有关的事？好吧，说到中国，毛泽东主席怎么样？因为他或许是
for the Chinese empire is going to collapse whatever happens. The imperial system that had been a feature of Chinese history for centuries, millennia, something was going to step into the gap. Maybe Mao's communism wouldn't have happened without the example of the Russian Revolution. The Russian Revolution wouldn't have happened without the First World War. So again, yeah, the Kaisersdeck shoes. But I think that Mao at the moment seems more influential than either Hitler or Stalin
中国帝制无论如何都会崩溃这一结局下的显而易见的人选。作为几个世纪、几千年中国历史特征的帝制体系，总会有某种力量填补这个空白。也许没有俄国革命的榜样，毛泽东的共产主义就不会发生。而如果没有第一次世界大战，俄国革命就不会发生。所以，再次说明，是的，都是皇帝的鞋子惹的祸。但我认为毛泽东在当时的影响力似乎比希特勒或斯大林都要大，
because the regime that he established is ongoing and plays an escalating role in world affairs at the moment. But of course, Mao didn't overthrow the imperial system. He overthrew the nationalists and the nationalists were weakened by a war with the Japanese. And so, I mean, there's all these things that come into play play that say the Japanese aren't involved in weakening the nationalists.
因为他建立的政权一直延续至今，并且目前在世界事务中发挥着日益重要的作用。当然，毛泽东并没有推翻帝制。他推翻的是国民党，而国民党因为与日本人的战争而遭到削弱。所以，我的意思是，所有这些因素交织在一起，如果没有日本人参与削弱国民党，
Are Mao's communists able to, you know, win the civil war? I mean, again, to me, it does come to the Kaiser's deck shoes question. I mean, that's that's a wonderful movie title right there. But and again, I would I would be open to the idea that the Kaiser was dragged along by his generals or or or as we always say in the United States, the president is often given a small range of choices, some of which are so outlandish that you end up choosing what the generals want anyway. And I think you can make a case that maybe the Kaiser was presented with a situation where he felt like he didn't have any options. I'm not educated enough to know what the internal deliberations were in the room between the Kaiser and von Moltke and all those people. I mean, the one thing I think is fascinating, though, is that point about your point you made about Britain and its empire, because I probably agree with Tom that the United States was always going to overtake Britain. And the European, the Western European colonial empires were probably always going to disintegrate in roughly the middle of the 20th century. I mean, maybe they would have done so later. But I think there's a couple of countries. So China would be one, but also Russia. Russia at the beginning of the 20th century was a massively industrializing kind of dynamic power. And it didn't have to take the path that it took,
毛泽东的共产党人还能赢得内战吗？我的意思是，对我来说，这依然回到了“皇帝的鞋子”这个问题上。这真是一个极好的电影片名。不过——再次重申，我会持这样一种观点，即威廉皇帝是被他的将军们拖下水的，或者正如我们在美国常说的那样，总统往往只能在一小范围的选择中做出决定，其中有些选择荒谬至极，以至于你最终无论如何都会选择将军们想要的东西。我认为你可以提出这样一个观点：也许威廉皇帝当时面对的是一种让他觉得自己别无选择的局面。我没有受过足够的教育，无法得知威廉皇帝与冯·毛奇（von Moltke）及其他人闭门讨论时的内部审议情况。不过，我认为有一点绝对吸引人，那就是你关于英国及其帝国的观点，因为我可能同意汤姆的看法，即美国超越英国是迟早的事。而欧洲的、西欧的殖民帝国大概也总会在20th世纪中叶左右解体。我的意思是，也许它们会晚一点解体。但我觉得还有几个国家——中国是一个，俄国也是。俄国在20th世纪初是一个大规模工业化的充满活力的强国。它其实不必走它后来走的那条路，
the sort of communist years. So a Russia that doesn't go communist and doesn't enter the First World War, where could you have had and this was early in their actual revolution, you know, 1917, 1918, you had other groups of people sort of arm wrestling it out. I mean, there might have been a Russian democracy or some sort of a parliamentary system. I mean, there's a number of ways it could have gone Lenin back to Russia to destabilize the situation there? I mean, what if, again, this goes back to the Kaiser, too, because if the Germans aren't in the war, do you send Lenin back? But I mean, how much of a difference does that make and if Lenin doesn't go back if Lenin stays in Switzerland writing angry essays and papers and newspaper articles uh does Russia go in a different direction because he seems to be a pretty pivotal figure all by himself yeah I'd agree with that so doesn't it Churchill said that it was like sending a chemical weapon or a biological weapon unleashing a virus yes yes yes exactly i think um yes no lenin lenin gets to st petersburg
也就是所谓的共产主义岁月。因此，一个没有走向共产主义、也没有卷入第一次世界大战的俄国，会走向何方呢？这发生在他们实际革命的初期（你知道的，1917年、1918年），当时还有其他政治派别在为之争权夺利。我的意思是，可能会出现一个俄国民主政体或某种议会制。我的意思是，事情有很多种可能的走向。列宁返回俄国以破坏那里的局势？我的意思是，如果——同样，这又回到了威廉皇帝的问题上，因为如果德国没有参战，你还会把列宁送回去吗？但我的意思是，这能带来多大的区别呢？如果列宁没有回去，如果列宁一直留在瑞士写着愤怒的文章、论文和报纸社论，俄国会走向不同的方向吗？因为他本人似乎就是一个相当关键的人物。是的，我同意这一点。所以，丘吉尔不是说过吗，这就好比送去了一种化学武器或生物武器，释放了一种病毒。是的，是的，绝对是的。我想，是的，不，列宁——列宁抵达了圣彼得堡，
doesn't he the finland station and basically says to all the bolsheviks you know we will we will take power within you know our plan is to take power by the end of the year or something and they're just dumbstruck because they don't see how they're going to do it they don't have enough support without lenin and his charismatic and his ruthlessness and his ruthlessness. Yeah, you're right. I mean, he obviously sets the tone for the revolution, doesn't he? Well, and so did all the Russians dying against the central powers. I mean, you know how war tends to damage the underpinnings and the foundational stability of states. And we all know what situation Russia was in by 1916, 1917. I mean, if there hadn't been a communist revolution, you were basically having a soldier-led mutiny
不是吗？到达芬兰车站，基本上对所有的布尔什维克说：“你知道的，我们将夺取政权——我们的计划是在年底前夺取政权，”诸如此类。而他们都惊呆了，因为他们根本看不出自己该怎么做到这一点。如果没有列宁及其个人魅力和铁血手腕，他们根本没有足够的支撑。而他的铁血手腕——是的，你说得对。我的意思是，他显然为这场革命定下了基调，不是吗？嗯，还有所有那些为对抗同盟国而死去的俄国人。我的意思是，你知道战争往往会破坏国家的根基和基础稳定性。我们都知道俄国在1916年、1917年时处于什么状况。我的意思是，如果当时没有爆发共产主义革命，无论如何，前线基本上也会发生由士兵领导的哗变。
on the front lines regardless. But maybe what you have in Russia, it's a bit like taking Hitler out of the equation in Germany in the 1930s. I think in both cases, if you take those charismatic kind of demagogues out of the picture, then you have, to my mind, probably a military authoritarian dictatorship of some kind, maybe. But it would be less brutal, wouldn't it? I think. Actually, in both cases,
也许你在俄国看到的情况，有点类似于20th世纪30年代在德国把希特勒排除在外。我认为在这两种情况下，如果你把那些具有个人魅力的蛊惑人家的政客从画面中剔除，那么在我的脑海中，你得到的可能某种程度上是一个军事威权独裁政体。但它会没那么残酷，对吧？我认为。事实上，在这两种情况下，
both Hitler and Lenin are characterized by a degree of cruelty, of utter ruthlessness that his opponents found shocking, didn't really know how to cope with. I don't know what Dan thinks about this. I think a white Russian regime would have had pogroms straight away, anti-Jewish pogroms, and there would have been some liquidation of people they blamed for their defeat. But they wouldn't have had an ideological project that decades later still involve famines and collectivization and all that sort of stuff. What do you think, Dan? Well, I think you can play with that counterfactual just imagining
希特勒和列宁都带有某种程度的残忍，一种令其对手感到震惊、且不知该如何应对的彻底的冷酷无情。我不知道丹对此有什么看法。我认为，一个白俄政权会立即制造大屠杀，即反犹太人大屠杀，并且会对那些他们认为应当为战败负责的人进行一番清算。但他们不会搞出一个几十年后仍然伴随着饥荒、集体化和诸如此类事情的意识形态宏伟工程。丹，你觉得呢？嗯，我觉得你可以通过假设白军赢得内战来推演那种另类历史，对吧？我的意思是，那将会非常有趣……我的意思是，不仅白军在赢得内战后可能会有所不同，而且别忘了他们与几个同盟国政府有着紧密的联系。没错。所以，也许像英国政府这样的一方可以转向获胜的白军，然后说：“好了，现在如果你想要援助来重建体制，我们要求必须满足某些条件，比如不能进行大屠杀。”我不知道，因为我认为这些人中的许多人会乐见该国此后的任何共产主义者都被消灭干净。但我确实认为汤姆的观点非常中肯，即这些如此体现20th世纪版本的意识形态政权——无论是希特勒主义还是斯大林主义——它们有着一种特殊的特质，它们不知何故将复仇感或苦涩感整合了进去。我的意思是，双方确实都有真正的对手，他们将现状归咎于这些对手。而且——有一种未明言的要求，即当时机到来时，那些人必须付出代价。对吧？所以无论是富农还是犹太人，或者无论是谁，
the whites winning the Civil War, right? I mean, you would have had a very interesting... I mean, look, and not only would the whites maybe have been different if they won the Civil War, but remember they had close ties to to several allied governments. Right. So so maybe someone like a British government can turn to the whites who are victorious and say, OK, now, if you want aid rebuilding the system, we're going to demand certain things are met, like, you know, not having mass executions. And I don't know, because I think a lot of those people would have been happy to see any communists liquidated in that country afterwards. But I do think that that Tom's point is well taken, that these ideological regimes that so encapsulate the 20th century version of those of Hitlerism or Stalinism, that those things had a particularly they'd somehow integrated the the the sense of vengeance or the bitterness. I mean, both sides had real opponents. They were blaming for the way things were. And and those and there was a sort of an unstated demand that when when the time comes, those people will pay. Right. So if it's the kulaks or if it's the Jews or whatever
都可能成为目标。换句话说，为了让那种不断寻找替罪羊加以指责的计划得以实现，最终必然会产生某种——我的意思是，我认为你在如今普京的俄罗斯也能看到这一点：你拥有一个替罪羊，而合乎逻辑的后续就是惩罚这个替罪羊，对吧？最后还有一个想法，关于是否可以说：现在判定哪位世界领袖对20th世纪的故事影响最大还为时过早？我特别想到的是——目前对核战争的核焦虑的回归；我对核武器的发展了解不多，但有没有哪位特定的政治领袖在核武器的扩散中发挥了决定性作用？会不会是——也许是罗斯福（FDR）？罗斯福还是斯大林？我的意思是——如果没有的话——我不知道这个问题的答案。
it might be. So in other words, for that program of constantly finding a scapegoat to blame is to come to its fruition there's got to be some eventual i mean i think you see this in putin's russia now you have a scapegoat and then the logical follow-through is to punish the scapegoat right just just one last thought on on might there be a case for saying that it's too early to tell which world leader made the biggest difference to the story of the 20th century and i'm thinking particular um of the uh the return to nuclear anxiety about nuclear war at the moment um i don't know enough about the development of uh of nuclear weapons but is there any particular political leader who plays a decisive role in the proliferation of nuclear weapons? Would it- FDR, maybe? FDR or Stalin? I mean, without- I don't know the answer to that.
有可能。所以换句话说，为了让那个不断寻找替罪羊来指责的计划结出果实，最终必然会有某种……我的意思是，我想你现在在普京的俄罗斯就能看到这一点，你先有了一个替罪羊，然后合乎逻辑的后续就是惩罚这个替罪羊，对吧？最后还有一个想法，关于是否可以说，现在就断言哪位世界领导人对20世纪的历史影响最大还为时过早？我特别想到的是……嗯……当前对核战争的核焦虑的回归，我不太了解核武器的发展，但有没有哪位特定的政治领导人在核武器的扩散中起到了决定性作用？会是……富兰克林·罗斯福（FDR）吗？也许是FDR或斯他林？我的意思是，如果没有……我不知道答案。
But you'd have them without either of those characters, surely, wouldn't you? Well, look, I mean, if one wants to play the game that way, one can say that there would be no nuclear weapons when they happened, if not for Hitler. Right. Because the war created a dynamic where there was a feeling of whoever gets to the finish line first on this is going to be the victor. Or the line about Einstein telling FDR in that famous letter about the potential for weapons creation out of nuclear fission. I mean, in my mind, if the war hadn't happened and it was peacetime and you weren't worried about somebody else beating you to the punch on that, maybe 10 more years elapse. But I agree that you're looking at something which is inevitable technological development. You might not have used them. It might have been interesting to see a world today with no actual examples of what atomic or nuclear weapons might do. Maybe one could argue that it almost was a benefit because I think we haven't used them since simply because we know how nasty they are. So you could argue the fact that Truman did use them and demonstrated what they
但如果没有这两个角色，你也同样会有这些，对吧？好吧，看，我的意思是，如果有人想用那种方式玩这个游戏，人们可以说，如果不是希特勒，当年就不会发生核武器。对的。因为战争创造了一种动态，让人觉得谁在这个问题上先冲过终点线，谁就会成为胜利者。或者说爱因斯坦在写给罗斯福的那封著名的信中提到核裂变武器潜力的台词。我的意思是，在我看来，如果没有发生战争，而且是和平时期，你不用担心别人会抢先一步，也许会再过去10年。但我同意，你看到的是某种不可避免的技术发展。你可能不会使用它们。看到一个世界上没有原子武器或核武器可能会造成什么实际影响的例子的世界，可能会很有趣。也许有人会争辩说，这几乎是一种好处，因为我认为我们从那以后就再也没有使用过它们，仅仅是因为我们知道它们有多么令人讨厌。所以你可以争辩说，杜鲁门确实使用了它们并展示了它们能
could do, perhaps was as decisive as anything that happened in the 20th century. Yeah, no, I have a problem with Truman too, because I really feel like he, when you talk about somebody who was in a very, and I have some sympathy too, but not in a position to be the person who should have been making those decisions. I think, you know, Truman didn't even know about the bomb, right? I mean, that's how cloistered he was. He'd only been a vice president for like five minutes. So when you take over, I mean, I was struck when we did a show on the early years of atomic weaponry and whatnot.
做到什么，这也许和20世纪发生的任何事情一样具有决定性意义。是的，不，我对杜鲁门也有意见，因为我真的觉得他，当你谈到一个身处一个非常——而且我也有点同情，但并不是处于一个应该做出那些决定的人的位置。我认为，你知道，杜鲁门甚至都不知道原子弹的事，对吧？我的意思是，他就是这么与世隔绝。他当副总统才大概五分钟。所以当你接手时，我的意思是，当我们做了一期关于原子武器早期历史之类的节目时，我感到很震惊。
I was, I guess it's a reminder. Sometimes you forget the institutional forces at play when a long time has elapsed. But there was a guy named Graves, who was the head of the U.S. program to develop the weapon. And he basically said that had they not used the weapon with all of the sunk costs and the opportunity costs, right, the things you didn't do because you put that into the way that the American people would have hung everybody up who made that decision by the nearest lamppost. Right. So in other words, it would have taken somebody of a Churchill or an FDR of a standing where they could have said, no, I don't have to worry about what the public backlash is going to be.
我，我想这是一个提醒。当过了很长时间后，有时你会忘记起作用的体制力量。但有一个叫格雷夫斯的人，他是美国开发该武器项目的负责人。他基本上说过，如果他们没有使用这种武器，算上所有沉没成本和机会成本——对吧，那些因为你把资源投入到那个方向而没有做的事情——美国人民会把做出那个决定的所有人都挂在最近的灯柱上。对吧。所以换句话说，这需要一个像丘吉尔或罗斯福那样地位的人，他们可以说，不，我不需要担心公众的反弹会是什么样。
We're not going to drop this weapon. Whereas Truman was the new guy. And he was I think he was simply following an already laid path and he didn't feel like there was. But he's also not deciding in a vacuum, though, is he, Dan? Because he's thinking he's not weighing up you know will i use the weapon and kill all these japanese civilians or will i not he's thinking will i use the weapon or will i authorize conceivably a land invasion of japan which based on what's happened in okinawa is going to be horrifically bloody and tens and tens of thousands of american GIs will die. And he probably, I mean, his argument
我们不会投下这个武器。而杜鲁门是个新人。而且他，我认为他只是沿着一条已经铺好的道路在走，他觉得没有什么——但他也不是在真空中做决定，对吧，丹？因为他在思考，他不是在权衡，你知道，“我会使用武器杀死所有这些日本平民，还是不这样做？”他在思考，“我会使用武器，还是会授权对日本进行一场可以想象的登陆作战？根据冲绳发生的事情，那将是血流成河的，成千上万的美国大兵将会死去。”而他可能——我的意思是，他的论点
to you would be, if he were here now, would presumably be, I took a terrible option, but the least worst option that arguably saved American lives. Yes. And the other thing that they had been talking about was a blockade, right? The Navy was all up for some sort of a long-term blockade. But there's all, I mean, you know, the arguments that could be made here. I mean, here's the bottom line, and it's horrific to say this, but the numbers of people that were killed by the atomic bombs, which look horrible by today's standard, is, I don't want to put a number on it because I don't know off the top of my head, but let's say a week's worth of fighting in that theater.
如果他现在在这里，对你来说，大概会是：我做出了一种糟糕的选择，但这是最不坏的选择，可以说挽救了美国人的生命。是的。他们讨论的另一件事是封锁，对吧？海军全力支持某种长期的封锁。但这里还有——我的意思是，你知道，这里可以提出各种论据。我的意思是，底线是这样的——说出这话很可怕——原子弹杀死的人数，用今天的标准来看显得很可怕，是——我不想说出一个具体数字，因为我脑子里记不清了，但假设相当于那个战区一周的战斗（造成的伤亡）。
I mean, and we used a quote, and I'm going to go from memory, so I'm sure it's wrong, but it was talking about the hundreds of thousands of civilians that were dying, I want to say, every week in that theater. And so to sit there and focus on, God, these are huge numbers. So 100,000 here, 100,000 there is to, they're still killing all those civilians in China. They have the option of holding prisoners of war sort of hostage. I mean, there's a lot that could happen. In other words, one might make the case that at least in determining what might happen, at least with the atomic bombs, you can say, OK, we'll do this and then this will happen. Whereas all these other choices leave the door open to a thousand unforeseeable little tributaries that might occur off the use of atom bombs, of nuclear weapons, that essentially has, in the long run, served the world in good stead. Because I wonder, what do you think would have happened had no atom bombs been used in the Berlin Wall crisis or in Cuba, the Cuban Missile Crisis? Wouldn't it be likelier in those situations, if Truman hadn't dropped the bombs that perhaps either the Americans or the Russians would have thought, oh, we'll just give it a go, just see what happens? I've made that exact argument. And what's more, had there been,
我的意思是，我们引用了一句话——我是凭记忆说的，所以我确信它可能是错的——但它是关于成千上万的平民正在死亡，我想说的是，在那个战区每星期都在发生。所以坐在那里只专注于“天哪，这些数字太大了，这里10萬，那里10萬”，就是——他们还在中国杀害所有那些平民。他们有把战俘当作某种人质的选择。我的意思是，有很多事情可能会发生。换句话说，人们可能会提出这样一个论点，即至少在决定可能会发生什么时，至少对于原子弹，你可以说：“好吧，我们这样做，然后就会发生这个。”而所有其他选择都留下了通往成千上万不可预见的微小支流的大门，这些支流可能会由原子弹、核武器的使用引发，而从长远来看，这实际上对世界是有益的。因为我在想，如果在柏林墙危机或古巴导弹危机中没有使用原子弹，你认为会发生什么？在那些情况下，如果杜鲁门没有投下原子弹，难道不是更有可能发生这种情况吗：无论是美国人还是俄罗斯人都会想，“哦，我们不妨试一试，看看会发生什么”？我提出过完全相同的论点。而且更重要的是，如果当时有——
I mean, can you imagine today's high definition phone cameras being able to, from 10,000 different phone users in Hiroshima or Nagasaki being able to show you in horrific with sound. I mean, it would have even had more of a sort of a deterrent effect. I will say the other thing that I think makes a difference here is that people will look at the photos of the victims and the cities and just go, oh, my God, this is the most horrifying thing in the world where similar photos do not generally exist from the Chinese situation, for example. I mean, or one of the things that I always talk about is most Americans don't realize when they make an argument about the atomic bombs, just how terrible the firebombing that was already going on was. From a functional standpoint, there's little functional difference.
我的意思是，你能想象今天的高清手机摄像头能够——从广岛或长崎的1万名手机用户那里——能够以可怕的声音向你展示吗？我的意思是，这甚至会产生更大的一种威慑效果。我要说的是，我认为在这里有所不同的另一件事是，人们看到受害者和城市的照片，就会说：“哦，天哪，这是世界上最可怕的事情”，而类似的奇观照片通常并不存在于中国的局势中，例如。我的意思是，或者我经常谈到的事情之一是，大多数美国人在就原子弹争论时，并没有意识到当时正在进行的燃烧弹轰炸究竟有多么可怕。从功能角度来看，功能上几乎没有什么区别。
I mean, the reason Hiroshima and Nagasaki were on the targeting list already is because the United States Army Air Force had already eliminated so many cities that they wanted cities that were still basically standing to test these things on. No point in doing it to Tokyo, where so much of Tokyo has been burned out already. How would you measure the results? Right. I mean, isn't it a famous thing that Robert McNamara, one of the architects of the Vietnam War said, when people used to ask him, are you a war criminal because of Vietnam? He would say, no, but I might be a war criminal because I helped with the logistical planning or whatever it was of the firebombing of Tokyo in which we worked out exactly the best way to incinerate huge entire blocks with all the people in them and all of this sort of stuff well and the few pictures that exist from that are truly of the sort that again if you'd had the high definition iphone type photos i don't even know but i mean there are there are photos
我的意思是，广岛和长崎已经在目标清单上的原因，是因为美国陆军航空队已经摧毁了太多的城市，以至于他们想要那些基本上还完好的城市来测试这些东西。对东京这样做已经没有意义了，东京的很大一部分已经被烧毁了。你如何衡量结果？对吧。我的意思是，这不是一件很有名的事吗？罗伯特·麦克纳马拉，越南战争的策划者之一，曾经说过，当人们过去问他：“因为越南的原因，你是战犯吗？”他会说：“不是，但我可能是一个战犯，因为我协助了东京燃烧弹轰炸的后勤规划或诸如此类的东西，我们在那次轰炸中准确地找出了焚烧巨大整个街区以及里面所有人及所有这类东西的最佳方法。”嗯，其中仅存的几照片确实属于那种类型——再说一次，如果你当时有高清iPhone那样的照片，我甚至不知道，但我的意思是，确实有照片——
that are i mean you look at it and you go how could a nuclear bombing have been any worse i mean it seems to have reached maximum horrific levels right and like they had said about future bombing of some of these cities, it was only going to make the rubble bounce. Well, you could make the same case for, I mean, how much more badly can you burn the civilians, you know? Now, before we get on to the third question, let us take a quick break, Tom, for some ads. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews,
那是——我的意思是，你看著它，然后会说：“核轰炸怎么可能更糟糕呢？”我的意思是，它似乎已经达到了最恐怖的程度，对吧？就像他们对这些城市未来轰炸的评价一样，那只会让废墟弹起来。好吧，你也可以为之提出同样的论据——我的意思是，你还能把平民烧得有多惨，你知道吗？现在，在我们进入第三个问题之前，汤姆，让我们先休息一下，听几条广告。我们共同主持《娱乐至死》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论的固定栏目，
splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. dot com that's the rest is entertainment dot com hello before we get back to part two it is uh time to look at what our friends at unheard
还有一点八卦秀。在我们的问答环节中，我们拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、额外单集以及提前购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertrainment.com。网址是 therestisentertrainment.com。点 com，网址是 therestisentertrainment.com。哈喽，在我们回到第二部分之前，呃，是时候看看我们的朋友 Unheard
un herd are getting up to uh and dominic i saw on twitter they're pushing back against her mentality encouraging independent thinking, Tom. Of course they are. That goes without saying, but it's the question of how they're doing it. And I saw on Twitter this morning that you had picked up on a prime example of how they're doing it
（Un Herd）在忙些什么了，多米尼克，我在推特上看到他们在抵制群体思维，鼓励独立思考，汤姆。他们当然在这样做。这是不言而喻的，但问题在于他们是如何做到的。我在今天早上的推特上看到，你抓住了一个极好的例子，展示了他们是如何做到的，
with relation to a series of books that I know is a great favourite of yours, The Flashman Books by George MacDonald Fraser. Tell us about what you saw. So I'm gutted about this because I would have loved to have written this essay. But in fact, Ares Routinos, who I believe is Unheard's foreign editor, has done it. Brave war correspondent as well.
这与一套我知道是你最爱的系列小说有关——乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽（George MacDonald Fraser）的《弗雷泽闪光记》（The Flashman Books）。给我们讲讲你看到了什么。所以我对此感到极为痛心，因为我本会很乐意写这篇文章的。但事实上，阿里斯·鲁西诺斯（Ares Rousinos），我相信他就是 Unheard 的国际新闻编辑，已经写了。同时也是一位勇敢的战地记者。
I think he's been in Ukraine. Yes. Well, he's written this article and he's actually done it brilliantly. So it's just as well he did it, not me. How annoying for you. Very annoying. It's awful, actually. I feel sick.
我想他去过乌克兰。是的。好吧，他写了这篇文章，而且写得极其精彩。所以他写了总比我写要好。这对你来说多烦人啊。非常烦人。实际上糟透了。我觉得有点恶心。
You actually recommended it. I feel sick. I did it whole only. I did it. I did it. No i did it i did it you know dominic that's a great great tribute to your character oh tom you're very kind so it's basically it's an advert for myself this but it's also an advert for unheard anyway um aris roussinos has picked up on the fact that it's the 200th anniversary of the fictional birth of the great
你其实推荐过它。我觉得恶心。我完全是出于好意。我这样做了。我这样做了。不，我这样做了，我这样做了。你知道吗，多米尼克，这对你的品格来说是一个极大的赞美。哦，汤姆，你太好了。所以这基本上——这其实是为我自己做广告，但这也是为 Unheard 做广告。无论如何，呃，阿里斯·鲁西诺斯注意到了这样一个事实：今天是虚构的伟大
imperial anti-hero harry flashman so flashman is, of course, the narrator of George MacDonald Fraser's brilliant series, The Flashman Papers, which are all about Britain's sort of Victorian empire, and Flashman has all these tremendous adventures. Because he's the bully from Tom Brown's school days. He is indeed the bully from Tom Brown's school days. But he becomes a lauded hero, despite being an absolute coward and paltrude. Exactly.
帝国反英雄哈里·弗雷泽（Harry Flashman）诞辰200周年。所以闪光记（Flashman），当然，就是乔治·麦克唐纳·弗雷泽那部精彩系列小说《闪光文集》（The Flashman Papers）的叙述者，这些小说全部关于英国某种维多利亚时代的帝国，而闪光拥有所有这些惊人的冒险经历。因为他就是《汤姆·布朗求学记》（Tom Brown's School Days）里的那个恶霸。他确实就是《汤姆·布朗求学记》里的那个恶霸。但他却成了一个备受赞誉的英雄，尽管他是个绝对的懦夫和卑鄙小人。正是如此。
So these are – I mean, it's weird how um as as aris rusanos says that the the books are sometimes seen as kind of celebrations of empire but they're actually not at all because they're all about the hypocrisies of empire and the um you know they're slightly cakist as we like to be on our podcast because this is they they're sort of having their cake and eating it a bit so there's all kinds of derring-do and the retreat from kabul and the indian mutiny and all this sort of stuff. But at the same time, they're very clear-eyed, I think,
所以这些——我的意思是，很奇怪，正如阿里斯·鲁西诺斯所说，这些书有时被视为对帝国的某种赞美，但实际上根本不是，因为它们全部关于帝国的虚伪，以及，呃，你知道的，它们有点像“鱼与熊掌兼得”，正如我们在播客中喜欢说的那样，因为这些——它们有点像既想拥有一切又想享受结果。所以里面有各种各样的英勇壮举、喀布尔撤退、印度民族大起义以及所有这类事情。但与此同时，我认为它们非常清醒地认识到，
about the world of the Victorians and the pieties and the kind of hypocrites. Yeah, exactly, of Victorian Britain. So anyway, Aris Rousanos did this brilliant article and I feel sad and cheated. Gutted.
关于维多利亚时代的世界、那些虔诚以及那种虚伪。是的，绝对的，维多利亚时代的英国。所以无论如何，阿里斯·鲁西诺斯写了这篇精彩的文章，我感到难过和被欺骗了。痛心。
Gutted that he's done it so well. And I have now nothing more to say about the subject at all. Okay. So go and read that and find out what ruined Dominic's day and read a whole host of other articles pushing back against herd mentality and encouraging independent thought. So the good news, Tom. Yes?
为他写得这么好而感到痛心。关于这个主题，我现在已经无话可说了。好吧。所以去读读那篇文章，看看是什么毁了多米尼克的一天，并阅读大量其他抵制群体思维、鼓励独立思考的文章。所以好消息是，汤姆。什么？
Do you know the really good news? I mean, it's maybe a surprise to some listeners. What's the good news? But it's that Rest Is History listeners get a special offer. Did you know this? Do you know the really good news? I mean, it's maybe a surprise to some listeners. What's the good news? But it's that Rest is History listeners get a special offer. Did you know this? Do you know? I did. Oh, you did?
你知道真正的超级好消息是什么吗？我的意思是，对某些听众来说这也许是个惊喜。好消息是什么？但好消息是《历史余音》（Rest Is History）的听众可以享受特别优惠。你知道这件事吗？你知道真正的超级好消息是什么吗？我的意思是，对某些听众来说这也许是个惊喜。好消息是什么？但好消息是《历史余音》的听众可以享受特别优惠。你知道这件事吗？你知道吗？我知道。哦，你知道？
I did. But share the good news with those listeners who may not have heard this before. Well, if you go to unheard.com slash rest, I'm doing that from memory because I've done it so often. U-N-H-E-R-D. Yeah, U-N-H-E-R-D. You can get a special offer and you can try 10 weeks for free because normally, Tom, it's a pound a week. I mean, which is very generous in and of itself,
我知道。但请把这个好消息分享给那些以前可能没听过这事的听众吧。好吧，如果你去 unheard.com/rest，我是凭记忆说的，因为我做过太多次了。U-N-H-E-R-D。对，U-N-H-E-R-D。你可以获得一项特别优惠，免费试用10周，因为通常情况下，汤姆，每周是一英镑。我的意思是，这本身就已经非常慷慨了，
but to get it for nothing. That's an absolute bargain, isn't it? Is, I mean, the Victorians would swoon at such philanthropy. They truly would. So that is what we are on this podcast, Victorian philanthropists. Exactly. And on that note, let's get back to our philanthropic venture, part two.
但能白白得到它。这绝对是个大便宜，不是吗？是啊，我的意思是，维多利亚时代的人看到这种慈善行为都会晕厥过去的。他们真的会的。所以我们在本期播客中就是这样的人，维多利亚时代的慈善家。正是如此。伴随着这个音符，让我们回到我们的慈善事业，第二部分。
So on the topic of the way that evidence and sources influence our understanding of the past, could I come to another big question? Sure. Thanks to writers like Suetonius and Plutarch, we have lots of biographies of Greeks and Romans. Which ancient empire do you wish had left us with a similar range of biographies? A, the Egyptian, the New Kingdom, perhaps particularly? B, the Persian, the Achaemenid Empire, or C that the Persian libraries are going to contain the information from Egypt, the information from Assyria, the information from Babylonia. And one could imagine that that would also include stuff from even the earlier civilizations in Mesopotamia,
那么，关于证据和一手资料如何影响我们对过去的理解这个话题，我可以切入另一个重大问题吗？当然。多亏了苏维托尼乌斯（Suetonius）和普鲁塔克（Plutarch）这样的作家，我们拥有了大量关于希腊人和罗马人的传记。你希望哪个古代帝国留给我们类似规模的传记？A，埃及，或许特别是新王国时期？B，波斯，阿契美尼德帝国，或者是C，波斯图书馆将包含来自埃及的信息、来自亚述的信息、来自巴比伦的信息。人们可以想象，这也将包括甚至来自美索不达米亚更早期文明的东西，
assuming that there'd been no logical break in the literature's history. But I imagine if you get your hands on the Persian library, you're going to find out about Sumeria in ways that you wouldn't find out about if you captured the Carthaginian library, maybe. Does that make sense? Yeah. You could argue, I suppose, couldn't you, that we know more about the Persians than the Carthaginians? The Carthaginians are a complete mystery, aren't they, really? I mean, so little we know about them. So't it be be more be filling more of a gap well there are there are biographies of you know of of persian kings written by greeks
假设文学历史中没有逻辑断层的话。但我想，如果你能接触到波斯图书馆，你就会以一种无法通过捕获迦太基图书馆所能了解的方式，去了解苏美尔，也许吧。这说得通吗？是的。我想你可以辩称，对吧，我们对波斯的了解比对迦太基的了解更多？迦太基人完全是个谜，不是吗，真的？我的意思是，我们对他们的了解太少了。所以这难道不是更能填补一个空白吗？好吧，也有——你知道的——由希腊人编写的波斯国王的传记，
by herodotus and people i mean yes and actually by by plutarch as well um but they're very greek i mean it would be it would be it would be nice to have the kind of the you know the the persian perspective on themselves but it's just the persians didn't write that kind of style. But I agree, the Carthaginians is kind of awful because they had incredibly rich libraries and the Romans deliberately incinerated them, all except for their agricultural manuals. Tom, if they got in their hands, and this is just a question for my own purposes, but if somebody had ever gotten their hands on the library at Alexandria, does that include all this kind of information we're talking about, or is that still going to be lost stuff? It's a good question. I mean, the ambition supposedly with Alexandria was to contain the entire knowledge of the world, but they were Greek. So generally they equated the knowledge of the world with what Greeks had written. You know, the obvious example, the obvious difference with that is that they do seem to have included Jewish writings, which inspires the translation of the Hebrew writings into Greek.
由希罗多德等人编写的——我的意思是，是的，实际上普鲁塔克也写过，嗯——但它们非常“希腊化”，我的意思是，能拥有那种——你知道的——波斯人对自己视角的传记会很好，但问题是波斯人没有写那种风格的东西。但我同意，迦太基的情况有点糟糕，因为他们拥有极其丰富的图书馆，而罗马人蓄意烧毁了他们所有的图书馆，除了他们的农业手册。汤姆，如果他们落入手中——这只是我出于个人目的提问——如果有人曾经得到了亚历山大图书馆，那里面是否包含我们正在谈论的这种信息，还是说那仍然会是遗失的内容？这是个好问题。我的意思是，据推测，亚历山大图书馆的雄心是收录世界的全部知识，但他们是希腊人。所以通常他们将世界的知识等同于希腊人所写的东西。你知道，显而易见的例子，与此明显的不同之处在于，他们似乎确实收录了犹太人的著作，这激发了将希伯来著作翻译成希腊语的灵感。
So I don't know the answer to that. And I don't think it's possible to know the answer to that. But the problem is, is that that style of kind of gossipy, racy biography that tells you whose mother was getting up to what and what his horse was called and all that kind of stuff. The Persians in particular seem to have seen that kind of style as below the dignity of the Persian king is the embodiment of truth and order, and therefore, details about what color hair he had or what sexual shenanigans he got involved with would simply not be permissible. Presumably, there must have been people who knew about this, and the dream would be to – maybe they wrote it up somewhere and it's buried in some desert or something. But I think it's unlikely. Well, but your point's well taken because a lot of this is this. It's not that a lot of these other cultures didn't write. It's that they didn't write like that. Right. They used it for different purposes. So that's a wonderful point. So one could make a case that a lot of our entertainment today follows the sort of Suetonius, especially Suetonius model. But what I can also say, because I heard from a lot of Iranians after we did a show on Persian history who talked about the fact that they simply told their history through other means. So you would have had the oral historians or some of these sagas and things that didn't that didn't follow what we would consider, let's say, a Thucydides kind of take on history, but more of the Viking sagas rather than something like Plutarch. Yeah, yeah, absolutely. I think I would go for the Egyptian simply because we did an episode on Tutankhamen and Akhenaten, and they seem such extraordinary figures, particularly
所以我不知道答案。而且我认为不可能知道答案。但问题在于，那种八卦的、风流韵事的传记风格，会告诉你谁的母亲在搞什么鬼，他的马叫什么名字之类的事情。波斯人似乎特别把那种风格看作是有失波斯国王作为真理和秩序化身的尊严，因此，关于他头发是什么颜色或他卷入了什么性丑闻的细节，简直是不被允许的。据推测，一定有人知道这些，而梦想将是——也许他们在某处写下来了，并被埋在某个沙漠里或什么地方。但我认为这不太可能。好吧，但你的观点很有道理，因为很大程度上就是这样。并不是说许多其他文化没有写作。而是他们不是那样写的。对吧。他们是为了不同的目的使用文字。所以这是一个绝妙的观点。因此，人们可以提出这样一个论点，即我们今天的许多娱乐活动都遵循苏维托尼乌斯，尤其是苏维托尼乌斯的模式。但我还可以说的是，因为在我们在做了一期关于波斯历史的节目后，我收到了许多伊朗人的来信，他们谈到这样一个事实：他们只是通过其他方式讲述他们的历史。所以你会拥有口述历史学家或其中一些传奇故事等，这些故事并不遵循我们所认为的，比如说修昔底德式的历史观点，而是更像维京传奇而不是像普鲁塔克那样的东西。是的，是的，绝对的。我想我会选择埃及，仅仅是因为我们做了一期关于图坦卡蒙和阿肯纳顿的节目，他们看起来是如此非凡的人物，特别是
Akhenaten. Akhenaten, yeahaten that whole kind of um because and because ironically because they tried to obliterate his memory and therefore it kind of survived the two you know tutankhamen's tomb survived and reliefs of of akhenaten survived in in the rubble of of temples and so on um it is possible to kind of patch together a sense of the drama of that story that makes you think it would be amazing, amazing, amazing to have a Suetonius style or even a Plutarch style biography of Akhenaten or Tutankhamen or that kind of set or Hatshepsut or Ramesses II. I mean, I deeply, deeply regret that because in Egypt, as in Persia, you have this sense that the personality of the king has to be dissolved into the grandeur of the pharaoh. But isn't that the point, Tom?
阿肯纳顿。阿肯纳顿，是的，那种整个——呃，因为——讽刺的是，因为他们试图抹去他的记忆，所以它某种程度上反而存活了下来，图坦卡蒙的陵墓存活了下来，阿肯纳顿的浮雕在神庙的瓦砾中存活了下来，等等——通过拼凑来感受那个故事的戏剧性是可能的，这让你觉得，拥有一本苏维托尼乌斯风格甚至普鲁塔克风格的关于阿肯纳顿、图坦卡蒙或那个时期的人物，或者哈特谢普苏特或拉美西斯二世的传记，将会是多么令人惊叹、惊叹、惊叹啊。我的意思是，我深深地、深深地为此感到遗憾，因为在埃及，就像在波斯一样，你会有一种感觉：国王的个性必须融解在法老的宏大之中。但难道不是这样吗，汤姆？
I mean, you'd never have an Egyptian. Yeah, it is. It's inconceivable. It would be a category error to think that they existed, but it would be, you know, if there were such a thing. It would be brilliant if they did. It would be wonderful. But wasn't Akhenaten, I mean, we're talking about a guy, I mean, correct me if I'm wrong. This is a guy who may have tried to foist a monotheistic, I guess, rolling up the traditional Egyptian panoply of gods into sort of a monotheistic sort of vein. I mean, had that happened, I think you open up the door potentially to
我的意思是，你永远不会有一个埃及的——是的，确实如此。这是不可想象的。认为它们存在将是一个范畴错误，但如果真的有这种东西的话。如果真的有的话，那将是极好的。那将是美妙的。但阿肯纳顿难道不是——我的意思是，我们谈论的是一个家伙，我的意思是，如果我错了请纠正我。这是一个可能试图强行推行一神教的家伙，我想是将传统的埃及众神万神殿融合成某种一神教的基调。我的意思是，如果那发生了，我认为你可能会开启一扇大门，
dissolving the entire Egyptian sort of royal style of writing into something. Because I mean, even the figures and the art form and the representations are much more realistic. I mean, maybe you get rid of that sort of the court way of looking at this thing and you open up the door. I mean, again, there's another one of your things. I mean, maybe Akhenaten's the reason that the First World War broke out. He has the most impact on the 20th century when you start the dominoes tumbling. All right. Well, we've got another counterfactual for you, actually, Dan. I mean, we did a podcast about counterfactuals in which we said we poured scorn on them, didn't we, Tom? But we've now broken our own rule completely because this is one of the great
将整个埃及式的皇家写作风格融解成某种东西。因为我的意思是，甚至人物、艺术形式和表现手法也现实得多。我的意思是，也许你可以摆脱那种看待这件事情的宫廷方式，然后打开一扇大门。我的意思是，这里又是你的一个观点了：也许阿肯纳顿就是第一次世界大战爆发的原因。当多米诺骨牌开始倒下时，他对20世纪的影响最大。好吧。好吧，其实我们还有一个反事实历史要抛给你，丹。我的意思是，我们做过一期关于反事实历史的播客，我们在其中说我们对它们嗤之以鼻，不是吗，汤姆？但我们现在彻底打破了自己的规则，因为这是最伟大的
American counterfactuals, probably the most famous American counterfactual of all. If the American Civil War, Dan, had gone differently, is there a scenario in which the Confederate States of America could still exist today? Okay, let me just say, I think the greatest counterfactual related to that is if the Revolutionary War goes the other way. In our dreams, in our dreams. That messes up the First World War also. Okay, so here's what I would say. I would say if the Confederacy wins,
美国反事实历史之一，可能是美国最著名的反事实历史。丹，如果美国内战的结局有所不同，是否存在美利坚联盟国在今天依然存在的剧本？好吧，让我这么说吧，我认为与之相关的最伟大的反事实假设是，如果独立战争的结局相反。在我们的梦里，在我们的梦里。那也会把第一次世界大战弄得一团糟。好吧，所以我要说的是：我会说如果联盟国获胜，
there's still a Confederacy today. Now, I don't think it looks like the dreams of Robert E. Lee and Jefferson Davis and those kind of guys, because I think slavery obviously goes away and all those kinds of things. But I think it's not such a weird counterfactual, especially if foreign powers came in and started aiding the Confederacy's cause. There would have been a lot of interest, I think, in seeing the United States split apart just from a power relation standpoint. And also just to jump in, the Confederacy don't need to win,
今天仍然会有一个联盟国。现在，我认为它看起来不会像罗伯特·李（Robert E. Lee）和杰斐逊·戴维斯（Jefferson Davis）这帮人的梦想那样，因为我认为奴隶制显然会消失以及所有这类事情。但我认为这并不是一个那么奇怪的反事实假设，特别是如果外国势力介入并开始援助联盟国的事業的话。我认为，仅从权力关系的角度来看，看到美国分裂会有很大的吸引力。而且顺便插一句，联盟国不需要获胜，
do they? They just need to not lose. You're right. Exactly right. That's a great point. And so I do think it's possible. And I think that's the difference between, say, a lot of Americans, yours truly, have talked about the current situation resembling something like a cold civil war. But the difference I always point out is in the Civil War of 1861, 65, you're talking about a a geographically divided country where with the exception of certain border states, you can nicely draw sort of the borders.
对吧？他们只需要不输就行了。你说得对。完全正确。这是一个绝妙的观点。所以我确实认为这是可能的。我认为这就是区别所在，比如说，许多美国人——包括阁下在内——曾谈到当前的局势类似于一场冷内战。但我总是指出的区别在于，在1861至1865年的内战中，你谈论的是一个地理上分裂的国家，除了某些边境州之外，你可以很好地画出各自的边界。
Nowadays, the United States is separated by voting districts within counties. You know, I mean, there's no. So in answer to your question, though, yeah, I think it could have happened. And if it had happened, too strong to countenance. It would become an inevitability of history that they were always going to break away, that people would be doing counterfactuals now. What if the United States had stayed together? And people would be saying, well, I mean, it's fanciful. The differences were too great. The cultures were different.
而如今，美国是由各个县内的投票区隔开的。你知道，我的意思是，没有那种界限。所以回答你的问题，是的，我认为这可能发生。如果它真的发生了，（这种想法）太强烈而难以接受。历史的必然性将会是他们本来就注定要分裂，而现在人们会在做反事实推演：如果美国保持统一会怎样？人们会说，好吧，我的意思是，这是异想天开。分歧太大了。文化不同。
They were always agrarian and industrial. People would have all these explanations, wouldn't they? And it's hard to imagine the Confederacy then voting voluntarily to dissolve itself or to reapply for admission to the Union, because it would mean in the eyes of their political elite, betraying the sacrifice that had been made for their independence, I suppose. Isn't that what they would be saying? Well, there's still futurists today who are predicting that the United States will break apart based on the exact same things you're talking about, that this was something that was built into the nation's DNA, if you will, a contradiction that was bound to fracture
他们一个永远是农业的，一个是工业的。人们会有所有的这些解释，不是吗？而且很难想象联盟国随后会自愿投票解散自己，或者重新申请加入联邦，因为在他们的政治精英眼中，这将意味着背叛为他们的独立所做出的牺牲，我猜。难道这不是他们会说的吗？好吧，今天仍然有未来学家预测美国将根据你刚才谈到的完全相同的事情而解散，即这是内置于这个国家DNA中的东西——如果你愿意的话——一种注定要分裂的矛盾，
along certain as you know, there's a there's a book out. I forgot what it's called, but but but it's a book basically that breaks the United States down into six or seven regions and then talks about how each of those regions are different, have a different history and a different outlook. And they use it to explain the modern day political situation. But a good but but it makes even more sense in the context of what you're talking about, that that some of these areas, while thinking that they are patriotic Americans, have a very different idea of what that means. And that something like that is an inevitable fracture point that if it doesn't happen in 1861, 65 happens eventually. And you just said about a cold civil war. So do you do you i mean we're all sort of familiar with the politics of the last decade or so in the united states but would you trace that back to the
沿着某些——你知道的，有一本书出版了。我忘记它叫什么了，但基本上是一本把美国分为六七个区域，然后讨论这些区域如何不同、有着不同的历史和不同的看法的书。他们用它来解释现代的政治局势。但一个好消息是——但这在你谈论的语境下更有意义，即其中一些地区在认为自己是爱国美国人的同时，对这意味着什么有着非常不同的看法。某种类似的事情是一个不可避免的断裂点，如果它没有在1861-65年发生，最终也会发生。你刚才谈到了冷内战。那么你——我的意思是，我们都对过去十年左右美国的政治比较熟悉，但你会把这追溯到
the civil war itself and the legacy and reconstruction and the unfinished business of abraham lincoln or whatever i mean do you think there's a lineage between the two? Wow, that's a great question. Well, the big debate over Reconstruction in the United States has always been whether or not there really was any. I mean, because of the way the politics sort of fell, including Lincoln's assassination and everything else, there's this feeling that Reconstruction was hurried, that it wasn't. I mean, you know, I've read people talking about how we should have had a more denazification, you know, post Second World War, the way we treated Germany kind of an approach. But but the way that the United States is set up, including the political parties at the time and the representation and everything else sort of opened the door to, let's call it a reconstruction light. So I don't know about that. I do think that one could make
内战本身及其遗产、重建以及亚伯拉罕·林肯未竟的事业或诸如此类的事情吗？我的意思是，你认为这两者之间存在某种血缘关系吗？哇，这是一个极好的问题。好吧，在美国，关于重建的巨大争论一直都是到底是否真的发生过重建。我的意思是，由于政治落脚的方式，包括林肯的刺杀和所有其他事情，有一种感觉认为重建过于仓促，并非如此。我的意思是，你知道的，我读过有人谈论说，我们本该进行更多类似二战后对德国那样的去纳粹化处理方法。但但是美国的体制设置，包括当时的政党、代表权以及其他一切，都为我们姑且称之为“轻量版重建”打开了大门。所以关于这一点我不敢说。我确实认为人们可以提出这样一个观点：
a case that certainly by the middle of the 20th century, you can see the sorts of trends starting to develop that are in full bloom now. So I do think this goes a lot farther than just the last 10 years. But I certainly think we're at more of a critical mass point than bloom now. So I do think this goes a lot farther than just the last 10 years. But I certainly think we're at more of a critical mass point than we were. So whereas you used to be able to, I mean, look at the late 60s, not to change gears, but look at the late 60s and the early 70s. I think people forget exactly how violent and destabilizing those times were. And I think, as you guys have pointed out, if we're looking at this from a history book 500 years from now, where time gets compressed and the 1960s look like they happened yesterday compared
当然，到20世纪中期，你可以看到各种趋势开始显现，而这些趋势在现在已经全面绽放。所以我确实认为这远远不止于过去10年。但我当然认为我们处于比以往任何时候都更接近临界点的状态。所以，虽然你以前能够——看看60年代末，不是要转换话题，但看看60年代末和70年代初。我认为人们忘记了那个时期究竟有多么暴力和不稳定。而且我认为，正如你们所指出的，如果我们从500年后的历史书来看待这个问题——那时时间被压缩了，与今天相比，20世纪60年代看起来就像是昨天才发生的一样——我认为他们会把所有这些看作某种连点成线的 数据点，而这是我们现在无法完全感知到的。好吧，丹，你提到了去纳粹化的类比。坚持反事实假设，如果联盟国至少坚持下来并设法谈判达成了一种岌岌可危的独立，难道北方各州不会因为觉得一直在为反对奴隶制而战而变得激进吗？这种感觉难道不会赋予北方一种比它参加内战时更强烈的使命感吗？从某种意义上说，这会使得一个极度反废奴主义的美国集团和一个仍然拥有奴隶制的美国集团之间产生一种长期的和平吗？这难道不会让这两个集团之间的战争在
to today, I think they're going to see these all as sort of connect-the-dot data points in a way that we don't quite perceive them now. Well, Dan, you mentioned the analogy with de-Nazification. Sticking to the counterfactual, the Confederacy at least holds out and manages to negotiate a kind of precarious independence, isn't it likely that the northern states would have been radicalized by the feeling that they had been fighting to combat slavery? And that that sense would have given the north a more burning sense of mission than perhaps it had when it went into the Civil War. And that in a sense, that would make a kind of long-term peace between a radically anti-abolitionist American bloc and an American bloc that still had slavery. It would make war between those two kind of inevitable in
长期来看变得不可避免吗？好吧，让我们把这一点进一步剖析，因为我认为你可能对北方美国废奴运动给予了过高的赞誉。它毕竟只是蛋糕的一部分，对吧？首先，尽管许多北方人可能不同意奴隶制，但他们当然不是不搞种族歧视，对吧？我的意思是，一个完美的例子可能是，想象南方没有炮击萨姆特堡并挑起战争。我的意思是，这有点像刚才说的南方不需要取胜，他们只需要存活下来。好吧，如果南方没有挑起内战，北方是不会为了摆脱奴隶制而对南方挑起战争的。
the long run. Well, let's break that down a little farther, because I think maybe you're giving too much credit to the American abolition movement in the North. It was still only a piece of the pie, right? And first of all, whereas a lot of Northerners would have disagreed with slavery, they certainly weren't non-racist, right? I mean, a perfect example might be if you imagine the South not firing on Fort Sumter and starting the war. I mean, this is a little like what was just said about the South doesn't have to win, they just have to survive. Well, if the South doesn't start the Civil War, the North isn't going to start a war to, you know, with the South just to get rid of slavery.
所以，我的意思是，我认为——如果有人开始谈论重新——让我们想象我们到了1900年，或者不妨说是1885年左右，因为在美国内战结束后，巴西等国仍然存在奴隶制。美国——特别是北方美国——会重新挑起美国历史上最糟糕的战争的想法。当然，这也是北方许多人无论如何都不觉得与自己平等的人。我的意思是，我来自——当谈到我的族裔血统时，我是一个典型的美国混血儿。但在我的血统里有相当多的爱尔兰成分。爱尔兰人既曾充满激情地与南方作战，也曾与奴隶制作战。但也有许多爱尔兰人在征兵暴动和所有其他事件中发起暴乱，他们的态度是：“我们凭什么要去为这个去死？我才不在乎呢。”你知道，我想说的是，我认为北方的废奴主义虽然强大，但它在某种意义上也是一种精英的情怀。我不确定普通美国人——除了可能不支持奴隶制之外——
So, I mean, I think I think that that had had had somebody started talking about re let's imagine we get to 1900 or maybe let's just say 1885 or something, because there's still going to be slavery in in Brazil and places like that after it ends in the United States. The idea that the United States, the northern United States especially, would restart the worst war in American history. And of course, it's the folks that a lot of people in the north didn't feel were their equals anyway. I mean, I come from, you know, I'm a typical American mongrel when it comes to my ethnic heritage. But there's quite a bit of Irish in my heritage. And the Irish people both fought passionately against the South and against slavery. But there were a lot of Irish people that rioted during draft riots and everything else whose attitude was, why the heck do we have to go die for this? I don't care. You know, I guess what I'm saying is, is I think the abolitionism in the North was powerful, but it was also an elite sensibility in some sorts of a sense. And that I'm not sure the rank and file Americans, other than maybe not being for slavery,
对于我们今天所称的“平等权利”这个概念有多大热情。这说得通吗？但你认为，即使联盟国坚持下来，奴隶制也会消失吗？哦，最终会的。绝对的。我认为从长远来看它是无法维持的。问题在于，什么才叫长远？我无法想象奴隶制会在20世纪存在很久。但我想你可以争辩说，种族隔离会持续更长时间。
were very passionate about the idea of what we would today term equal rights. Does that make sense? But you think that even if the Confederacy had held out, that slavery would have gone? Oh, eventually. Absolutely. I think it was untenable over the long haul. The question is, is what is the long haul? I can't imagine slavery exists very long into the 20th century. But I suppose what you could argue, though, is that segregation would have lasted longer.
它一直持续到了1965年。我的意思是，是的。所以，我的意思是，无论如何它已经持续了相当长的时间。我的意思是，对。但它持续了。我的意思是——但这就是关于它有多么顽强的一个观点，它持续了那么久，甚至在一个经常由痛恨种族隔离想法的人（如罗斯福或其他人，他们本身并不是本能的种族隔离主义者）管理的联邦政府下也是如此。而且它存在于这样一个国家中：在这个国家的某些州，同样有很多人对种族隔离的想法感到惊恐，然而它仍然存活了几十年。所以想象一下，在一个没有这些人的社会里会怎样？
It lasted until 1965. I mean, yeah. So, I mean, it's lasted a pretty long time anyway. I mean, right. But it lasts. I mean, that's but that's a point about how resilient it is, that it lasts as long as it does, even with the federal government that is often run by people who hate the idea of segregation, FDR or whoever, who are not themselves instinctive segregationists. And it exists in a country where there are states, again, where a lot of people are horrified by the idea of segregation, and yet it still survives for decades. So imagine it in a society where there aren't those people.
换句话说，就像一个更富裕、更安全的南非版本。因为我脑子里想的就是南非。我的意思是，南非，种族隔离是什么时候结束的？南非是在20世纪90年代初。是的，但是，你知道，我要——我要——我要告诫大家，不要把北方各州看作在说这句话时是多么地温和良性，即这些人可能反对奴隶制，但他们不一定想在自己的街区里与黑人群体和谐共处。我的意思是，种族主义是一个全国性的问题，即使奴隶制本身是北方许多人所痛恨的东西。请记住，这里也有一个宗教成分。我的意思是，很多这种反奴隶制的东西来自于那些将此视为某种罪恶的宗教传统中的人。但他们在重建之后对于佃农制没有任何问题。对于——你知道的——他们有时确实有。但我的意思是，不允许黑人入住的酒店。我想说的是，
In other words, like a richer, more secure version of South Africa. Because it was South Africa that I was thinking. I mean, South Africa, you know, when did apartheid end? South Africa, early 1990s. Yeah, but, you know, I'm going to I'm going to I'm going to caution against looking at the northern states as so benign on saying is that these people might have been against slavery, but they weren't necessarily wanting to live in harmony with black folks in their neighborhoods. I mean, racism was a nationwide problem, even if slavery itself was something that was reviled by many in the North. And remember, there's a religious component to this, too. I mean, a lot of this anti-slavery stuff comes from people who are part of a religious tradition that looks upon this as as a kind of a sin. But they didn't have any problems with sharecropping after the Reconstruction. They didn't have any problems with, you know, they did sometimes. But I mean, hotels that wouldn't allow black folks in. I guess what I'm saying is, is that
奴隶制作为一个如此极端的异类，远远超出了大多数人所能忍受的程度。但即使在北方，他们也确实容忍了一些并非奴隶制但也不是自由的事情。但归根结底，我们都认为如果20世纪60年代的情况有所不同，联盟国今天依然可能存在。我——你知道，在这里——我知道我可能是一个异类，每次我这么说时都会收到愤怒的信件。我认为，如果北方没有仅仅决定
slavery being such an outlier and so above and beyond what most people could stand. But they sure put up with things even in the north that weren't that wasn't slavery, but wasn't freedom either. But the upshot is that we all think that Confederacy could still exist today had the 1860s worked out differently. I don't you know, here's and I know I'm probably an outlier here and I always get angry letters when I say this. I think it would have been really difficult for the Confederacy to have won the war if the North didn't just decide
他们不再想要继续下去，联盟国本会很难赢得这场战争。恩纽斯（Ennius）的那句老话怎么说来着？对吧？只有当对手认为自己战胜了，胜利者才算真正胜利。我可以理解北方因为代价太高而停止战争。但如果北方坚持进行一场几乎类似于二战那样的无条件投降式的战争——它总是会赢的。
that they didn't want anymore. What's the old Ennius line, right? The victor is not victorious until the opponent considers themselves so. I can see the North stopping the war because it's getting too costly. But if the North persists in an almost Second World War, unconditional surrender sort of thing- It's always going to win.
他们不再想要的。就像恩纽斯的古老名言一样，对吧？只有当对手认为自己战胜了，胜利者才算真正胜利。我可以看到北方因为战争代价太高而停战。但如果北方坚持以类似于第二次世界大战那种无条件投降的方式继续下去——它总是会获胜的。
Yeah. It's hard to see the Confederacy winning. What about if Britain gets involved there? That's a big counterfact. Yeah. Then it's like France's role in the Revolutionary War. Then I agree. Then the tables change significantly. So Dan, as a man, or I mean, since you're a man who does five hour podcasts, I guess we should have expected this because we have got through, I think, well, we've barely got through four of our 10 questions. We have been going for almost an hour, which I know to you is nothing, but to our listeners, we don't want to try their patience. So what we'll do is we will come back for a second episode, and that will be out on Thursday.
是的，很难看出南部同盟怎么能赢。如果英国介入呢？那是一个重大的反事实假设。对，那就有点像法国在独立战争中的角色了。那我就同意了，形势就会发生重大变化。所以，丹，作为一个男人——或者说，因为你是一个会做五小时播客的人，我想我们本该料到这一点，因为我们才刚过完，嗯，我们甚至还没过完十个问题中的四个。我们已经聊了快一个小时了，我知道对你来说这不算什么，但对于我们的听众，我们不想考验他们的耐心。所以我们接下来要做的是，我们会回来录制第二期，这期节目将在周四发布。
Now, if you can't wait till then, the Rest Is History Club will have both episodes in their podcast feed right now. Oh, it's exciting. And if you're interested and you're not a member of the Rest Is History Club, go to restishistorypod.com to sign up. We will see you regardless on Thursday for samurai bodyguards, for whether the West could have lost the Cold War and other monumental questions of history with Dan Carlin. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening and access to our chat community,
如果你等不及到那个时候，“历史其余部分俱乐部”的播客动态里现在就已经有这两期节目了。哦，这太令人兴奋了。如果你感兴趣，且还不是“历史其余部分俱乐部”的成员，请访问 restishistorypod.com 注册。无论如何，我们周四见，届时将与丹·卡林一起探讨武士保镖、西方是否会输掉冷战以及其他历史上的重大问题。再见。感谢收听《历史的剩余部分》。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，
please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip. And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的剩余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论和一点点八卦的地方。在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目以及优先购买现场门票的权利，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。